India is launching one of the world's
largest international repatriation
missions flights to 13 countries will
start on Thursday while warships have
already been deployed to bring back
hundreds of thousands of workers
stranded overseas due to coronavirus
travel restrictions all flights to India
were suspended in late March arriving
passengers will be screened segregated
and then quarantined Korea
Hosea ligase is a lawyer practicing at
the Indian Supreme Court he's
representing an Indian expat who's filed
a case for speedy evacuation good to
have you with us live on al-jazeera sir
who are you representing and I was the
backstory to your client I represent a
client an Indian citizen who was based
in the UAE by the name of mr. swoon
disease he's been very actively involved
with the dice for a magazine device for
our anyway
I mean fly this issue stating that a lot
of you know marginalised in the poorer
section of the dice for are finding it
extremely difficult their livelihood is
affected conditions and labour camp
seems to be you know completely
challenging challenging aspect and he
also highlighted the concern that you
know citizens are unable to return back
to their homeland
based on the same than we decided to
initiate a public interest litigation in
the Supreme Court of India flagging some
of the concerns of our fellow citizens
who are trapped in countries like the
UAE UAE primarily because it has the
largest number of expatriates Indian
origin there the petitioner seeks to one
highlight the broad issues which are
being Fain's there and for the illusion
of a proper protocol a proper legal
framework on which this entire
evacuation efforts of the Government of
India could be kind of underpinned we
felt that there's a huge legal vacuum in
which this entire process of evacuation
potentially may operate and that was a
concern which we try we are trying to
bring before the Supreme Court because
we look at if a question not only as a
movement of people from point A to point
B but as a whole process is screaming
starting from point A from the host
country
make sure that they're asymptomatic
ensure that once I come back to India
the larger rustic almonds are in a
position to handle these multitudes
which come in and to ensure that their
quarantine well let me just and so let
me just interject that and we'll take
this piece by piece let's talk about the
fact that your client will be moving
from the UAE to India so what's his
understanding of being tested at the
moment in the UAE and the approach that
he will be he will receive once he lands
on Indian soil he is of course acting in
the larger public interest but what are
the concerns which he was highlighting
in the UAE was that you know the number
of people which are there especially as
expats from salvation particularly from
India the numbers are so high that
effective screening in these labor camps
may be very challenging and he felt that
a lot of these people would like to
return especially people who are not
affected or are not infected at this
stage if they're asymptomatic he felt
that it is better in today's conditions
and the kind of economic difficulty
people are facing he felt that it would
be better for them to come back to their
homeland and to ensure that they go to
the quarantine process and that they're
able to be back home this was one of the
concerns he highlighted and he is more
than willing to be subjected to whatever
medical test screening is not really way
but presumably with Indian state states
as well you talk about the framework
that you'd like to say the Indian
government implement for the movement of
people both from respective countries
back to India itself are you confident
the Indian government can do this
considering they couldn't or they were
perceived not to be able to move
domestic migrant workers from one state
to the next because of trains planes and
buses being halted and people couldn't
get back to their home villages the
initial issue pertaining to migrant
workers happened during the the midst of
the lockdown and it was an unprecedented
lockdown starting from day from Sunday
of March late Sunday and the lockdown
led to
a complete closure of state borders and
workers were trapped today what has
happened is there's a conditional
lifting of the lockdown process so today
I think legally speaking the lockdown
has been lifted the Government of India
like even the state governments is
they're looking at a very unprecedented
situation you know it is not like a
normal it's not even like a normal
disturbance or war where India in 1991
with a lifted almost a million-plus
people from Kuwait but that was the case
where you lifted people and brought them
back home and they could just go home
there were no international pandemics or
public health emergencies which stopped
them from moving around today the
position was different because you now
have to ensure that the masses of people
are being brought into a plane the first
threshold checking happens the airport
so you have to ensure that the checking
there happens which means there's a lot
of involvement of the government of
India with the host country once that is
done once they transported back the
state governments of a whole process of
foreign time means thousands of people
to ensure that food is given to them to
ensure medicines are given ensure clean
water hygiene conditions
lest you have a bigger disaster waiting
to happen
what we were trying to point out was
actually the lack of a proper framework
and we believe that a proper protocol a
proper and legal protocol or procedure
established by law would enable the
returning people to be not discriminated
if at all there is a arbitrariness or
some kind of non transparency in the
process as lawyers we fell or as the
utility ideal client felt at that stage
that people should be given an even
chance to come back and not merely based
on their paying capacity this is a
concern because we're running out of
time but just a brief and final question
repatriation for any national from any
country is never a free ticket back home
for many of the migrant workers that are
coming back from the Gulf they went to
the Gulf because they come from poor
backgrounds and send most of their money
back to India to support their families
can they afford the airline ticket to
get them back home see I believe mostly
people whom you're talking bought were
were really marginalised and not very
capable of
having a savings culture because I'm
sure they send money back like you
pointed out the excuse amount or
remittance coming back
and these people contribute on a big way
back to their local economy Wow
this is the time and I believe the
government of India should at least if
not free tickets maybe maybe very
challenging but the government could
look at subsidizing are every
discounting these tickets especially for
people who can be identified to be
people who do not have the economic
capability of buying that that that use
of ticket back home I think they're in
the government probably or rather if I
may use a rather strong way of putting
it the government is duty-bound to
ensure that its people come back home
without you know after screening process
is done and that ticket should be
something with the government is low it
should be looking at people who cannot
afford it I think that is a primary duty
of all governments could even can pay
for it well into Korea cause a vergis a
thanks so much for joining us from New
Delhi very appreciate Han